right so speaking of which tomorrow is
really great opportunity for those
looking to work in education a teacher
hiring fair is happening at 10 A.M over
at Somerset Academy in North Las Vegas
so principals from over 20 different
charter schools are all going to be
conducting on-the-spot interviews they
are looking to fill a wide range of jobs
including all K-12 subjects they're
looking for special ed assistance
support staff all for those without
teaching licenses by the way multiple
alternative licensing groups are going
to be there to answer your questions so
for more information again this is
happening tomorrow you can go to
8newsnow.com